شهدت عملات خمس دول عربيه على الاقل
اضطرابات شديده في سعر عملتها الوطنيه
خلال الفتره الماضيه اكثرها حده كان في
لبنان وسوريا اضافه الى مصر والسودان
والعراق وتونس يختلفوا اسباب تراجع هذه
العملات من بلد الى اخر لكن القاسم
المشترك فيما بينها هو انعدام والاستقرار
السياسي والامني في تلك الدول
اداره الاقتصاد الوطني في ظل ظروف
الاضطراب السياسي
والاقتصاديه المتصاعد في العالم جره الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا وتداعيات ازمه تتفشي
وباءنا وقد ترك هذا الواقع واثره البالغ
على حياه سكان هذه الدول الذين يواجهون
ظروفا معيشيه صعبه
لو تراجع عملات بعض الدول العربيه اتخذ
مساره منحنى مساره منحنا كارثيا في بعض في
بعضها وقياسيا في بعضها الاخر
فقدت اكثر من 90% من قيمتها
وفقا للمنظمات الدوليه فانا قرابه 70% من
الاسر اللبنانيه واجهوا صعوبه في تغطيه
نفقاتهم الاساسيه خلال العام المنصرم وفي
سوريا
تراجعت العمله الى مستوى سته الاف و500
ليره للدولار الواحد في السوق السوداء وهو
ما ادى الى ارتفاع اسعار السلع والوقود
بحيث يعجز المواطن عن شراء الوقود والطعام
والاساسيات الاخرى السودان ايضا قفز سعر
صرف الدولار الى اكثر من خمس 2800 جنيها
بعدما كان في حدود 45 في العام 2019 وفقا
للمنظمات الدوليه فان ت هذا العام تشير
الى حاجه ثلث سكان البلاد الى مساعدات
الانسانيه
خفض الجنيه مقابل العمله الامريكيه بنسبه
40% خلال العام المنصرم ووصل الى 27 جنيه
ومعه وصلت نسبه تضخم في البلاد الى ذروتها
بتسجيلها نحو 27% ايضا